hi shelby
hey steve how's it going
good in fact we should probably start
with bonjour bonjour
voila because we are going to be
continuing uh to explore the french
language
and uh
what we're going to try to do is sort of
touch on
one key element each time
which
then i want you to notice and hopefully
it also helps you notice other things in
the language
it's not possible to explain everything
that happens in the language
and it's certainly not possible to
remember you know if i were to explain
everything that happens assuming i knew
what happens in the language assuming i
could explain it you wouldn't remember
it so you sort of got to start noticing
more and more
things
and and that's why of course we put so
much emphasis on listening and reading
because the more you listen the more you
read the more things you start to notice
certain things fall into place
and that allows you to notice other
things that you hadn't noticed before
and so there's a gradual
gradual process of getting used to the
language
and also i think it's helpful too
to develop certain habits like like the
habit of listening while doing other
things some people say they can't do
that you mentioned last time that you
are able to do that yes uh you can be
listening while uh doing the dishes or
in your car or whatever it might be yes
and i i've been doing that a little bit
since our last video
okay so i thought that today would be
interesting to focus on you know we are
going to get into sort of nouns and
gender and adjectives and
and verbs and tenses and all those
things that that people have trouble
with but the first thing is is basically
the sentence the structure the word
order for a positive statement
then for a a question and for them
you know either a negative or a positive
answer and the many stories are a great
place to do that because
there are 60 many stories and every
single mini story is followed by
questions and every
and it's what we call these circling
questions so you have a statement from
the story you have a question that
repeats basically the same words and
then you have either a positive or a
negative answer so let's see if we can
go there on on your screen and see what
we can notice about word order in french
all right sounds good
by the way last week we were noticing
certain things about pronunciation
and i hope you are noticing things
relevant to french pronunciation and
even trying to i suggested that one way
to get sort of the rhythm
because it's it's so difficult some of
these
things that are difficult to pronounce
in french uh it's
it's sometimes easy to pronounce them in
individual words but much more difficult
in a sentence and so therefore it's
useful to sometimes practice reading a
sentence maybe listening to it and then
reading it trying to capture the
intonation of the native speaker even if
you stumble over the individual words
and then keep doing that and keep doing
that and pretty soon you will be able to
produce the e or the or the o or the ah
on the fly in the middle of a sentence
it won't happen overnight but it's
something that's worth uh practicing
awesome
and you are practicing that right
yes
all right
so let's go to one of the many stories
um
i mean we can do we can start with you
have we done story number let's go to
number six
okay right all right which is new
and uh i'll just remind people that um
the mini stories are written in such a
way that the first 20 lessons are all in
the present tense and thereafter there's
just a mixture of tenses
okay
all right i'm gonna i i guess i was in
the middle of the fifth one so here we
go
okay
all right
so uh again because
uh
pronunciation is always there i mean
pronunciation is kind of something that
we gradually get better at and the
better we get at pronunciation the
better we understand
so comprehension improves as well so
let's maybe just read a couple of um
sentences here and then we'll
we'll flip through to the questions
so could you read the first sentence
there i can sure try
okay
yeah okay it's not that you don't know
that it's because you missed it so one
should never get upset about the little
things that slip by because we didn't
notice i know that you know that an e
with a
an axon
as it's called is pronounced a
and and we also know that uh there's an
s on the end of the fatigue because
there's two of them right mm-hmm
so that agreement but we'll get into
agreement some other time
but uh we see there that the word order
is very similar to english right john
and frederick are tired
now we say at night
in the evening and in french they don't
say in the evening they just said the
evening
okay
so uh let's read the next sentence
okay
ensembl
uh
this
is
again as we discussed last week
right no no s if if it had if the next
word had started with a vowel
then it would have been is we would hear
the s but because it starts with a
consonant it's silent
so ilmaj so there again homage yeah just
reading through these is an opportunity
to go over some of the stuff that we
covered last time and that is that many
uh letters in french are simply not
pronounced
right so ilmange so when we get to verbs
we'll see it's a bit of a problem
because if you say image you don't know
if it's he eats or they eat it's
pronounced exactly the same right okay
uh but you get used to all this stuff
so image ensemble
again i i remind you that
anyone with a spanish
sort of background is going to want to
say le repa but it's actually
okay
the e without an accent is up
the e the meal of the evening
is november
at 7 o'clock
these never
noticed in french particularly in france
less so in quebec they use the 24-hour
clock
not exclusively but more than we do and
we also use the 24-hour clock but not as
much as they do okay but we see again
that the word order is very similar yes
read the next sentence
now just to make you uh to remind you of
how inconsistent things can be in french
in fact it's
it's one of these words
the next word doesn't begin with a vowel
i know
and you have to learn these are there's
a few words like that
and so whereas it's
ils
but what we're seeing here though is
that the word order is very similar to
english
yes so so let us now i don't know if we
can flip ahead a few pages you can
always go back in
it'll convert your blue words to white
but you can go back and save them again
so you're not losing anything okay
people sometimes get so worried well i
didn't know that i shouldn't have made
it known and it doesn't matter if you
come across it again you don't know it
you just save it and and the the word
count
recalculates
so i knew i knew that word i just really
wanted which one is that well then let's
go through the words you don't know
which one don't you know well the blue
ones
okay let's do them all right let's do it
i mean
fatigue i can definitely assume what
that means right right yeah
oh you should you know one thing i would
do is jean and frederick i would x them
both
so yeah how do i do that again well the
easiest way to do it is just hit x on
your keyboard okay awesome i had
forgotten that yeah and you can move to
the next one with your arrows so now
marge do you know i guess you've had
you've looked it up yeah
no and that one i had i had remembered
before that right
one thing i do when i'm going through
and i come across yellow words if i now
feel i know them that's my opportunity
to uh change the status so if they were
a status one i might move them to two or
three if i'm not totally confident or if
i absolutely know it
and annoying to me means knowing it in
the context it doesn't mean that you'll
be able to remember to use it that'll
come gradually over time but as long as
i'm comfortable i understand it in the
context i'll move it to know i can
always move it back later on
it's important to keep moving forward
and not saying gee if i can't you know
use it
whatever then i don't know it i i don't
approach it that way i just keep moving
forward i can always move it back
yeah this is my first time seeing this
word right mark it as a three
but you know what it means it's uh meal
food yeah we even have that in in
english
i think so let me know
okay
now one thing you might want to do
uh as a habit on link is to save a
phrase like le producer
says it's said a little differently than
in english it's kind of a useful phrase
is that really hard is that really how
they always say dinner
no no they can say
supe dna or whatever but very often logo
paliswar yeah okay good to know
uh let's see but normally they would say
you know you know let's let's have
dinner together about dna ensemble you
know dna is
is a verb is it's a noun
you'll get used to that but this one
here is also useful that
okay
now
is like to relax i guess i've never seen
that or before right now one thing that
you we will you know we're getting into
all kinds of stuff but that's fine we'll
have another opportunity to focus in on
it but
so there are these reflexive verbs
okay so to relax is is suit it down like
insert it on very relaxed all right
and uh
it's just useful uh to determine that is
to stretch out but in soothing time they
relax okay okay so yeah different
meaning if it's reflective or
non-reflexive right
so these should be safe together
yes i remember that one yeah story
that's to watch
um if what i find if it's a blue word if
i know it i don't even need to save it
like television
then i don't touch it because then it'll
automatically not save
right the minute you touch it and you
move on it'll save it
but you don't want that because you know
television so you just pass it it'll
it'll be blue and as you turn the page
it'll turn to uh to white
okay
right on this page
yeah we can turn the page
okay
now
you know what we can continue just to go
through and save the blue words and then
we'll get to the questions and
so
so i read that next sentence
[Music]
uh
i have no idea how to say 20
in french i haven't listened to this yet
oh no that's fine
what is fun though is
what is fun uh from my experience
uh
and i'm talking about like persian and
arabic where it's nothing no meaning
the audio is noise there's nothing there
and you go back three months later and
it's all clear
and so all of the things that you're
experiencing now is it's very
interesting because you're beginning
it's the you're just starting with the
language so it's all full of stuff you
don't know what to do
and you'll go back there well we're
gonna have a number of these sessions
and you'll see just how much of it
becomes clear but again
remember that that
that
they right
so
anytime you have ill
the ending is ent
of the verb
and it's not pronounced
not pronounced
so you might want to say that but but
ilmet the s is not pronounced because it
comes before a consonant and the ent is
not pronounced
so eden met they put
lefi's elites
and what's more the t there doesn't
really drag on to the ah like often i
say there's a liaison
aventa
it's unfortunate that they have written
20 as
you know the numbers yeah really right
it's v-i-n-g-t
and maybe i'll go back in there
v-i-n-g-t and again i'm not gonna the g
is not pronounced right
i've entered
[Music]
this is the same as
spanish i think maybe not it isn't
italian anyway takes
a ban
i'm back
i don't know what this means um
oh bath okay
yeah oh warm okay
okay
um
so what we're seeing john john takes a
bath
very warm so in english word order we
would have said takes a very warm
dive
correct there the the adjective comes
after and that's often the case not
always but often the case more often the
case
i think in english we always put the
adjective first
a big card and we never say our car big
exactly
yeah but in french they often put the uh
the adjective after the noun
but not always
but not always okay
not always but mostly
that makes it just so much more fun
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know and that's why i always say
with all these grammar things you don't
even worry about it because you cannot
possibly remember and i'm sure you can
find a grammar book that tells you the
rules as to when the adjective comes
before
the noun and when it comes after and of
course it's impossible to remember that
and but just through enough reading and
listening you'll eventually get used to
it
okay
so next sentence
all right
do you want me to read it
voila now two reflexive verbs
he showers himself
and he brushes himself the thief
okay
okay
yeah i'll say i know that one that's a
cognate that's spanish
as well
yeah it does and seduce i don't know why
that didn't say if i can remember that
one
yeah
so there's a lot more reflexive like
that would not be reflexive in english
you wash myself you don't shower myself
yeah i don't brush myself to teeth yeah
but they
they do in french so these are things
and again no amount of explanation just
get used to hey we have another
reflexive verb yes today should be on
reflexive verbs totally well and yeah
this is only familiar to me because it's
equal as spanish but yeah if i had not
learned spanish
this would be super weird
exactly
all right so next one
jean
great spanish accent there so first of
all li is for is to read and we notice
it's the same word as the word for bed
okay because uh four sentences up he met
delphi
to bed
oh okay
so
lee same
word
exactly lily the bed or
li which comes from lee jolie
uh to read
sodor another reflexive
yeah i
i'm not gonna say i can recognize that
word yeah no but it's it's from
you know dormia to to sleep mm-hmm
[Music]
reading
okay so he falls asleep reading yeah
okay
all these are that's a structure that
you'll get used to we're not going to
get into it now but ah
it could be any verb it's like while
doing something cool cool
okay
okay
should be the month
you're doing a lot better one thing now
because this is a mini story the first
uh
part of the story is
is uh talking about them
jean and frederic
and then the second portion it's either
frederick well no it's it's jean who's
talking now and she says frederick
like frederick
oh like a frederick
that's the third person plural but here
is us
i'm not going to get into the verb but
start to notice that the verb form
changes so here again uh ilmaj
so the verb changes
you with your spanish are quite familiar
with the fact that verbs change with the
person
in english we only have the one form
that changes which is the s at the end
of the first the third person singular
in the present tense but in french they
all change
so like spanish
okay oh you hit your daily target good
for you great
okay
okay
not office maslow part
of no by the way you know you're already
reading so much better than when we
started this lesson
note again
that because it's we it's ours son right
yes
and
uh not have uh but
no no
no
no no no no it's like
spanish has the great advantage of being
like you can you can read a word you've
never seen before and it's it's written
the way it's pronounced
spanish release in french
oh you is ooh
ooh means where ooh ooh
is
okay and we'll go for the last one
[Applause]
because it's again it's reflexive so
whereas the reflexive form for
they they il
but here is nunu
we
stretch ourselves
we relax right now
again not overnight but slowly you get
more and more confident in the different
nasal sounds because there's om and
there's ah
and there's
okay
because it's new
new new new daytona
but
when you have a
an s between two vowels it's
z sound
so it's not television it's television
sure
how good we're getting close to
questions so
uh read the next sentence
okay next next sentence okay
actually
anytime you see any without an accent
it's
not one thing you'll often hear in
french is it's no trophies but when they
speak quickly you only hear you don't
hear they are the e so it could you
could say no trophies our son or not
feast you don't hear the ari not face
very good next one
may maybe
okay
okay federico sandor rapidamo
perfect
so now we get to word order when we come
to questions so give us the statement
um
the statement here yes no the question
the first question
okay oh right right so for uh
john
what am i saying
it's okay
frederick's song okay frederick
johnson
right
what you have to think of is
it's a bit tiring doing what you're
doing now because you're kind of half
apprehensive that i'm going to correct
you each time and you're stumbling even
things that you know you gotta look at
like three months from now for me three
months from now you're going to plow
through this like
it's a breeze like it's old hat that's
what people
people and i know you've been through it
in spanish where you went from starting
into spanish and eventually becoming
fluent in spanish so the same will
happen here so now ask the question
um
fredrik johnson
so what's happened here is
but of course it's they are tired right
now
so the question goes frederick
so you see that when they ask a question
they reverse the order
which is what we do in english
we say they are tired are they tired
[Music]
same not very difficult
except for the
um
the subjects are still first in the
sentence in the question which is right
so yeah they yeah
so we would say in english say
you know fred and john are fred and john
tired right yeah i would start here we
are
good yeah they tend to do that if
there's two
yeah subject are they tired right this
is we'll see different forms we'll even
see the eska form they'll be different
forms yeah but this is one form okay
okay next page
okay so here's the answer to the
question
yeah we elson fatigue
[Music]
and the answer is
no
you know i got to go in there and change
this and and write out the words for the
the numbers that's not good yeah i've
heard numbers one through
yeah
absolutely somewhere
yeah okay so none is
this sweet uh
no no no
no of course
this is our first introduction to the
negative innermost pa so the in french
you need two words to say no
right you can't say in homage at this
so they sandwich the verb
between two negative the negative
consists of two components
i will see this again and again so don't
worry about it you'll see it often
enough that this is easy you'll see this
so often that it'll just be second
nature
so give us the negative statement again
uh no in the mom
[Music]
okay the numbers
don't worry about them they come up and
eventually you get them so
i never worry about numbers okay next
one
office
excellent
auntie is unfair
okay
until
is a bit confusing but typically when
it's two l's and an e like that i lle
uh
it's not pronounced
okay so
not always
[Laughter]
like the word for brilliant is prion
brilliant
right but the word for million is
so nothing is very consistent okay
voila and the answer is
no
again over time you'll notice but it's
anyway
now
one thing that again i don't need to get
into too much but you know duffy
you could
they don't have any daughters
whereas if it was
like they don't have one daughter or a
daughter they have a son
but don't worry about it you'll come
across it later
okay
uh you know what i think we have covered
a bit here
of word order
uh because i can't explain everything
that happens but at least i think you
should be in these many stories
attentive to
some of the things we covered today
you know pronunciation again not because
you want to
pronounce it correctly now necessarily
but so that you gradually start to
notice the pronunciation
while you're listening which is
eventually going to help you
uh we covered the uh the numbers i
apologize that we don't have them
written out in the lessons that's all
right
and uh the negative is nupa
always two
and and oh i should we should have
mentioned too that
if you have no
followed by a vowel
as innum pad of fe
then you'll see there that we uh down
there they removed it oh because to have
a uh uh o together is very difficult so
it's innopa and so it's an apostrophe
the apostrophe represents the missing e
right because this end here would be
like this no
right exactly
so even
fee
that's very efficient of the french
yeah
yeah lots of stuff that's not so much
fun but that's efficient you don't by
the feet because that's how you say it
you know it's like it's like
contractions in english you know can't
cannot can
same idea
um
okay i think that's enough and uh i now
uh you know enjoy the remainder of the
mini stories
and
next week we'll look at uh some other
aspects maybe we'll get into gender or
get into verbs
and uh but hopefully
gives you a little something to um
hopefully doesn't discourage you
no
okay no
good all right then so i look forward to
sorry go ahead i was just under pressure
here i hadn't i hadn't heard some of
these words before
that's right that's right i'm you know
i'm taking your advice and i'm focusing
a lot on
listening and reading so i haven't
really
pronounced these words right very much
so it feels very awkward
it's just that when you are reading
there is a tendency to want to pronounce
them to yourself
therefore it's helpful to know how
they're pronounced or you can develop
the habit of
pronouncing them wrong all the time now
when you were doing a lot of listening
like if you were if you had listened to
this story beforehand
and it typically in my case i would
listen to a story like this three or
four times
and then i go in and read it
and then i have a bit of momentum
because i've heard it
for sure that's good
yeah that helps me
and um what was that gonna show i was
gonna say something else but at any rate
no just keep going with with the stories
listening
noticing
and um
oh yeah i know i was going to say when i
started into arabic and persian
it was difficult for me to read much
more difficult than it is for you
because
here it's all a lot of recognizable
words from english and spanish and it's
written in the latin alphabet yes that
helps
but when you get started it's sometimes
helpful to read along with a tutor
because then it helps you in your
reading
because then when you go back to reading
you feel a little more confident that
you're pronouncing things correctly at
least to yourself sure so you may find
that as we progress it won't be quite so
necessary to read along in the lesson
but at an early stage i think it's kind
of useful helps get you going okay okay
shelby good luck in your french
bon bon shots they say they say
like uh
have courage
revoir
[Music]
you